[Music]
let me tell you a story about my
situation you couldn't leave the crib tv
was my staycation from the crack of dawn
you feel my every need i watch you so
much i forgot how to read cedric the
entertainer opened the 2021 emmys with
quite the star-studded musical number
wrapping his own version of bismarck
keys classic just a friend ll cool j was
first up to
join the game
and tons of celebs stood up to sing the
chorus
rapper and comedian lil dicky also took
the mic
tv's my lifeline dave's here is show
time i came up on friend's curb and
seinfeld i'm so white but love me some
blackish pant 15 bins and i enjoy ted
lasso but 20 nominations is a lot and
then there was this moment rita wilson
showing off her impressive rap skills
and yeah billy porter was all of us
freaking out with excitement
[Music]
safe to say the number had the whole
room up on their feet and singing along
e.t spoke with cedric on the red carpet
just before he kicked off hosting
television's biggest night and he teased
that his opening number and the 2021
emmys would be packed with excitement
it's gonna be fun man we're going we're
going super energetic tonight paying a
little homage to one of the great
hip-hop artists so it's gonna be dope
we're gonna use it you'll see what it is
you'll see what's going on
you